hello and welcome to sampling pop 129
yes I played them a lot some years ago
but nowadays not so much of a frequent
guest them so you have to accept it
Reggie gambit let's see I get this back
and it gives me the pawn bag immediate
left it is a very solid way to play for
black I am I think that Y term is a
little bit easier to play the black is
definitely okay in this position I to
play on the queen city of course with
the bishop on g2 before is preventing c5
and a 595 there's Ruby one that's not an
issue in general electric look a b-1
look FC one and then try to play for
breaks yep so maybe one
not sure if 95 actually helps them and
the night is not doing that much them an
idea from is also night g5 in this
position looking or being a little bit
annoying on the bishop and then play 94
to c5 but I can first of all complete my
rook placement yeah now he stops this I
wonder if Quincy five is actually an
idea now I don't think so doesn't it
doesn't really feel right now it's more
interesting he has to go back then
between trade cannot trade the Queen's I
even if is good in this position heads
go in for Quincy sell a 97 would be
funny and then Quincy violent no
activation fee should be three actually
at the green strapped okay so a year mhm
three first prevent any Bishop g4 stuff
so yeah we should be through I guess or
a five in science you might bring the
night around okay let's put it here
92 b3 c5 these kind of things 195 can
also go by age five Wow what about 90
for him g5 is a dramatic move and night
on c5 or a five would be pretty good
let's go for c5
i wonder if i should call Bishop g4
indisposition traders Bishop here
[Music]
no probably not
it's not an the 93 that would be a way
to lose this position which is it's
already I mean you can only do this now
a blundering stuff or let me do
something really stupid because
strategically speaking this is more or
less winning four wide I cannot take on
d4 would be a deadly self in but it's
really difficult to give them any advice
I'm also just threatening to take on
istics plus h for f1 f1 h 194 is good
yeah black is completely pushed back to
the to the final ranks take just the
tech down 25
I could have may be taken immediately I
mean I should have taken once and then
you fired I mean what is this move here
I don't see a move yeah we should be for
how to do it
+ d 4 is hanging so you still have to
see maybe I should really just cover it
here with with the Queen or so Queen d2
I mean we don't don't really see
anything for him if I just pile up now
look g4 and double
look Jane made through create made Clank
resources yeah I what God slowly slowly
pushed back there out of this opening
position yeah this is more dangerous
than it looks I mean I think once I once
i get this bind in here it's it's not
easy for black you cannot move from
anyporn basically and I can play on the
queenside quite quite easy name yeah h3
maybe not necessary but it was
comfortable a gphi this is weakening
even more I think here it's close to
losses yeah engine basically agrees and
white has a big attack it's a good thing
sometimes if you don't put pawns in the
center or any like here and once they
arrive there right with a vengeance now
now this is extremely problematic ok I
can go we should be forward I wasn't
sure this is Butchie for it looks
devastating but yeah I can take really
30 km that's true and then what you want
but the slow method wasn't bad
threatening simply the mate and there's
no defense to that yeah ok guys thanks
for watching